welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian chapter 13
just revealed the biggest detail yet
about the child
spoiler warning before i continue
because this is super hot off the
presses
just go watch the episode please and
then come back the child we have been
affectionately and lazily calling baby
yoda
does have a name and that name is grogu
yes grogu g-r-o-g-u
or in our bash greg askgreck
breaking from the why name pattern of
other members of the species yoda and
yaddle but sticking with a pattern of
sounds i make when i try to buy yogurt
when i'm on quaaludes
google yoga i know i know you're
probably still just gonna call him baby
yoda the same way we still call mando
mando even
after the season one finale reveals his
name to be din jaren but that is what
you get when you wait months and months
to name your characters
your viewers will fill in those blanks
these things belong to the world now i
am gonna break down how we learn this
information
and how it is completely changing the
game going forward tommy's and my
reaction and our wikileaks after show is
coming later today stay tuned for that
and my frame by frame easter egg
breakdown of all the stuff that you
missed in this episode is coming
tomorrow
yeah it's a big week of romando gobble
gobble okay so chapter 13 opens by
revealing rosario dawson as ahsoka tano
looks so good former jedi from clone
wars and rebels
padawan and friend to anakin skywalker
before parting ways with the jedi order
and parting ways with most of her clone
trooper friends after order 66 so sad
but returning chronologically in rebels
with two white light sabers that she got
from inquisitors and then ending rebels
joining sabine wren
in search of ezra bridger now we find
her on the forest planet corvus having
pissed off the local magistrate of the
city kaladan
mando finds her they fight but they stop
when he drops the name bo katan crees
and then ahsoka sees it the child i hope
it's about him
and then using the force ahsoka
non-verbally communicates with baby
oda's mind and memories and from that
link she is able to derive
so much of what we have been wondering
grogo and i can feel each other's
thoughts
he was raised at the jedi temple and
coruscant many masters trained him over
the years
at the end of the clone wars when the
empire rose to power
he was hidden someone took him from the
temple
then his memory becomes dark
i've only known one other being like
this
a wise jedi master named yoda that's
right
grogu was trained at the jedi temple on
coruscant and many
masters trained him over the years now
stepping away from this grogu is
actually the same exact age as anakin
skywalker making him
five years older than ahsoka so they're
roughly contemporaries
they're probably at the jedi temple
around the same time meaning grogu
must have been kept just out of sight in
that jedi temple maybe i guess getting
private tutoring
some accelerated program for yodeling or
just the nursery he is a baby he does
age super slow but then
right around order 66 when the child was
around 22 years old
someone took him from the temple saving
his life and he was hidden and from
there
his memory goes dark and yes ahsoka did
obviously know master yoda so it is nice
to see the memory of him bring a smile
to her face because
i can't imagine much does for her
anymore now looking ahead there is
so much more to explore with the
socatano and her search for grand
admiral thrawn
an amazing character from the star wars
universe and her
most likely crossing savers with mob
gideon we are going to go deep into that
in wikileaks and in the breakdown and in
future
videos but in this video i just want to
stay on this thread of grogu
in his past who rescued him from the
jedi temple during order 66
and what was this dark period between
that tragedy and denjarin finding him
28 or so years later who were those
people he was initially with who guarded
him so fiercely
on arvala 7 until mando and ig 11 killed
them all but real quick before we move
on i want to thank the ridge for
sponsoring this video
they're the makers of these sleek front
pocket wallets
the ridge wallet is light and sleek and
industrial it is designed to fit in your
front pocket unlike those bulky 90s
style back pocket wallets that give you
an america's ass
no one would want a salute this one is
their black titanium model
it's so slick you can do some sleight of
hands with it i don't know how to do
magic i just feel cool holding it when
you head out the door for like a quick
errand
to get whatever essential stuff that you
need you just take the minimal
essentials with you to make for a quick
hassle-free transaction that's what
these ridge wallets are perfect for the
ridge wallet comes in over 30 styles and
colors including carbon fiber burnt
titanium
it holds up to 12 cards and still has
room for cash
every ridge wallet comes with a lifetime
guarantee and they will let you test
drive it for 45 days
and then send it back for a full refund
if you don't love it but it's got thirty
thousand five star reviews so you know
they're doing something right they also
have great backpacks and travel bags
with rfid blocking pockets optional
device charging batteries and ridge
wallets are apparently chainsaw proof so
you know when jason voorhees kicks down
your door
at least your credit cards will be okay
get ten percent off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to
ridge.com new rockstars that is rich dot
com slash new rockstars user code new
rockstars find the link in the video's
description okay this mystery gap period
and baby yoda slash grogu's early years
is now
narrowing from fleeing the jedi temple
during order 66
to the moment he was found on arvala 7.
presumably some unknown jedi must have
fled with him
most of the jedi were killed during this
attack even the younglings
but some did escape interestingly the
game jedi fallen order hinted that
one of them might have been master
yaddle so if the order thing is rebuilt
you think any jedi will come out of
hiding what makes you think there are a
jedi hiding
well growing up we heard tales of a
green pointy-eared legendary jedi master
and
are you talking about master yoda who no
no i'm talking about master yano
now this is not outright confirmation
that yadl survived it's just speculation
but it is interesting that she came up
like this
in a game that released in the same week
the mandalorian premiered on disney plus
in november 2019. that clever lucasfilm
group thing could be up to something
with yattle but whoever saved grogu must
have parted ways with him
because by the time mando finds them
decades later the group guarding him
are not jedi or anyone a jedi would
affiliate with
actually if you go back and re-watch
that first episode a lot of these
answers can be found
just by taking a closer look at who
those guards were and how they connect
with other throwaway details we have
seen on the series ever since these
guards are all the
nekto race identifiable by their horns
and either orange or green skin
the nekto cartel is the gang that took
over the crime syndicate of job of the
hutt after his demise in return of the
jedi
and this series is just five years after
that and back in my breakdown of chapter
10
i pointed out how on mando's way out of
tatooine with boba fett's armor
the gang of bandits who tried to trap
him and take that child
was led by another nikto now i don't
mean to say
every neato is a gangster related to the
same cartel
yeah actually i am saying that this
neighbor could have been from that same
group that was guarding the child back
in the first episode but another
forgotten detail from that first episode
came up with werner herzog's client
character later revealed to be working
on behalf of mob gideon a guy who was
more than happy to kill him off but back
in chapter one he told mando this
proof of termination is also acceptable
for a lower fee
that is not what we agreed upon i'm
simply being pragmatic
huh so recently in chapter 12 dr
pershing revealed his plan to try to
harvest midichlorian rich blood
from this force-sensitive donor in order
to pump into those strand casts
probably in the plot to resurrect
sidious and or spawn snoke
check out my other videos on that but dr
pershing needed the child alive
in order to harvest those midichlorians
they're living creatures in his cells
when he dies those things
move on and so moth gideon would need
the child alive too yet
the client considered it a totally
viable pragmatic
option to simply kill the child and
indeed ig 11 told mando his assignment
was to simply kill the kid
the commission was quite specific the
asset was to be terminated
so looking back what did that client
mean by pragmatic
well i think this tells us that while
this client had
insights to the child's location maybe
he bought off sources within that nicto
cartel he was not fully aware of
pershing and gideon's plot to use grogu
for genetic experiments to the client
the child was a valuable asset that to
his knowledge was
not in the hands of the jedi or the new
republic either in his view
if luke skywalker or the new republic
were to find grogu
it would be game over there would be no
way the empire could ever bounce back so
to him
it would be better to just simply
neutralize that threat altogether so the
question for us ahead is now
where grogu was during this intermittent
period essentially during the entire
galactic civil war
and the five or so years after the
galactic civil war when the new republic
was rising
i have to believe that if luke skywalker
was around trying to rebuild the jedi
order he would not be
so careless as to let something like a
baby yoda slip through the cracks
so i'm assuming the football fumbling
happened sometime during the galactic
civil war which posed an interesting
possibility
because we have an obi-wan kenobi series
in the works right now
it is totally possible that baby yoda
sometime during that period
could have been saved by obi-wan kenobi
and that we will see that child
show up in that kenobi series that is in
development folks i just think the story
of grogu during this period it's gonna
be told to us by one of two people if it
happened during the galactic civil war
euan mcgregor obi-wan kenobi if it
happened after
maybe mark hamill cameo in as luke
skywalker support new rockstars by
checking out all the great options on
our official merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com
subscribe to this channel hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
ea boss follow new rockstars thank you
for watching
i have spoken
[Music]
you